we have a really exciting panel to
discuss this morning kind of the
intersection I I think brought up a
bunch of people from LA a bunch of
people from New York but to really talk
about the intersection of tech and
entertainment which over I would say the
past couple years have really taken off
and sort of in a new awesome direction
and we'll go through and sort of
introduce everyone and talk about what
they're up to and and and take it take
from their home obviously we'll open it
up for for some questions Steve let's
let's start with you and talk about big
frame you call it a next-generation
media company tell us a little bit about
big frame but but also tell us what a
next-generation media company looks like
okay yeah I can start there I mean what
we mean by a media company really is is
that we're not creating software to sell
the media companies we're not trying to
make money as a management company we're
trying to be a media company and that
that's a company that creates content
brings audiences and content creators
together packages that all together and
then finds a way to make money either by
selling it to advertisers or e-commerce
or some other way and so it's kind of an
uncommon model to get financed but
venture capitalists don't tend to you
know invest in that and so we've got you
know we have we have found some that are
open-minded on that model but really
were a lot more working working on the
model that we saw produce lots of
humongous companies the last time there
was a major video distribution
disruption which was when cable happened
and so we're we're really saying how do
we use the dynamics of this online video
market which is YouTube meet social
meets all kinds of different formats and
and how is that going to define the next
big brands like able to find em TV and
tnt and ESPN and so and just and talk
about youtube for a second just talk
about kind of how that that what it's
done for disruption and what it's done
for for your business as well well I
mean yeah the YouTube gets a lot of sort
of a lot of people shooting arrows at it
because it's it's so big and powerful
but I mean you have to remember that if
it allows anybody anywhere in the world
to upload content have it be accessible
on any device in almost any country
immediately right so thanks you know
that was pretty pretty pretty good job
there engineering-wise that worked out
well and you get you get to make money
from it and so the the thing that
YouTube is going through right now I
think is that there there's tension
inside as there are most big companies
between well we're monopoly should we
just sort of act as a platform where
should we go for the next the next step
of sort of dominating and really make it
a place for premium content to survive
and I think that that's kind of where
the fight is going on right now that
they spend a lot of money very publicly
a year ago funding all this premium
content and they forgot to market it and
so it didn't work that well and they
also didn't know how to sell it so you
know everybody made all this content
nobody saw and no advertisers got to use
it and so that was that was a mess and
so we're all looking at them now saying
was you know don't stop like you you
know we have to keep learning and keep
trying and so what big frame is really
focused on is well independent of of
YouTube and what they're going to do in
terms of grants what is a sustainable
online video media company look like and
so we we look at the data we work with
hundreds of content creators we're
trying to find a way to help them make a
living but we're also trying to find a
way so that basically we can acquire
customers for cheaper than that we can
monetize them for and we're looking at
all kinds of content isn't working yeah
I mean it but it's it's right there on
the edge right look just like most most
startup companies are where every every
month our revenue goes up or we're
looking at our margins in our costs
we're following lots of different models
that we're seeing having worked in pure
play like we look a lot of vice and what
they've done we look a lot it buzz buzz
feed and the you know those kinds of
content companies successful blog
companies like how do digital-only
companies manage their costs organize
their company work with advertisers
develop brands do all those things and
for us that just the difference is all
of our content
is video and all of it is online video
which means it's snackable shareable
searchable it meets all of those
criteria let's a lot more to talk about
mark you're the co-founder of tanggal
which crowdsources videos for big brands
what is what does that mean tell it tell
us a little bit more about what you what
you do yeah first of them I'm not Zach
Braff and I apologize but I are we
breathless yeah I saw him there I don't
others but I Elijah sitting over there
we actually I came we came out of
Hollywood I work for Warner Brothers I
work for talent agency initially a lot
of our business was born more out of
frustration than anything um so you know
our goal and building tanggal was to
build a meritocracy for talent so we the
biggest need out there was coming from
brands it also helped that they were
willing to pay for it so we've now built
a community of 50,000 filmmakers writers
ID ators you know we always said the mom
from Iowa may have a great idea or may
want to engage with a brand she may not
have the core skill set to bring that
idea to let via video so let's allow her
to collaborate with a community of
filmmakers um a lot of whom specifically
in Los Angeles were waiting to be
anointed in some cases so he said if we
can build a platform where they can you
know prove their worth I it will give
them opportunity and choice choice and
we'll also reward them for that so and
it's yeah it's been a pretty good run
we've obviously with um we've worked
with PNG Lego Mattel colgate perhaps you
name it also talked about so so you made
a your community I guess made an ad for
the superbowl for seventeen dollars
right talk about amazing Marge 17,000 I
was never get dolla stop it so sorry
sorry which is which is still not enough
where were my zeros up okay yeah yeah
it's funny we'd actually done is a
series we probably did about 30 programs
for colgate working with with Y&R that
their agency arm it wasn't intended for
the super bowl and I think you know you
hear it every day or whatever the term
the shore is whether it's native
advertising or authentic advertising
emotional storytelling arm you know they
had 30 pieces of content they produce
they were thinking about what to run on
the Super Bowl that there was one that
stood out it was one that we had
produced and I think that's happened you
know very often as of late a lot of our
content has percolated up and I think
it's a result of you know not being
diluted by having too many chefs in the
kitchen arm there's a lot of sort of
freedom in what we do within the
platform where we just there's timelines
there's not a six to nine month process
a lot of the content will produce
happens in four to six weeks um so it
stood out for Y&R they ran the Super
Bowl and it made that guy's career so
beyond the 17,000 he's now not only
earned a lot of tonga but he's gone on
to become a professional commercial was
the commercial I was for speed stick
yeah which I actually saw running
yesterday so he still get residuals so
and obviously and obviously YouTube ads
are so you know now I mean I'm sorry
super bowl ads are four million dollars
a year was just announced River
30-second spot so brands are obviously
still going to the traditional places
where all the eyeballs are and they're
also trying to figure out now what to do
on YouTube and and have you noticed sort
of how they're navigating those I know
from our in there just starting to
figure it i'm in it i think and these
guys know better than I do I think for a
long time I probably been preaching the
value of content and owning a
conversation and you know taking the
guard rails off allowing it to just be
fluid storytelling I feel like they've
there's been these massive content
audits by a lot of these companies and
their now just finally realizing that
you know google has all these bells and
whistles to justify the content so let's
start creating it adds scale
continuously which is nice to see
Stephen let's talk about slated which is
your company you call it an angel list
for film funding tell us tell us a
little bit about what what you're
working on well first off how many
people here have heard of angel list can
I had a show of hands all right there's
a small percentage is slated is an
online matchmaking service essentially
so if you if you look at the whole
umbrella term of crowdfunding under
there it includes everything from
impulse donations on IndieGoGo
Kickstarter to Angel list secondmarket
slated which is professional equity
investing
and different asset classes so slated is
more on that end of the spectrum but the
idea was that over the years looking at
where is the disruption really occurring
in Hollywood we're with content in
general everybody started looking at
distribution you've got a film made
where can I get it shown where can I get
it shown in on an online platform how do
I monetize that how do I match it with
advertising there was a massive amount
of competition and so when everybody was
heading in that direction we decided to
go in a different direction which was
well how do you get that stuff made to
begin with and the number one challenge
all content makers have is getting their
films financed so that was the toughest
nut to crack because film finance for
anybody who's participated in it is one
of the most wild and wooly worlds and
you really need to have been in the
business to see how dysfunctional and
inefficient it is but not so long in the
business they become completely cynical
and jaded and want to give up so we
tried to come in right at a moment where
everybody was looking for help in 2008
after the market collapsed and a lot of
money was taken out of independent film
financing and Studios shut down their
specialty divisions and we're doing only
bigger and bigger budget films and
crowdfunding on one end is really for
the sort of a fifty-dollar impulse
donation we decided to come into middle
and help out the independent feature
film makers who are making the one to 20
million dollar budget films and those
are the films that are most often
getting the Oscar nominations that's
what most audiences love and really
connect with but that's where all the
money it disappeared so slated came in
and created simply a matchmaking service
between investors filmmakers and the
industry so it's much more easy now if
you will to sort of browse around
Hollywood identify projects you might
like be matched to it automatically
almost like a dating service so you can
much more efficiently get to the
projects you might really like get to
know those filmmakers and go and invest
in those its accredited investors yeah
so slated is only for professional
investors it's a members-only community
so you need to be invited in or you need
to know two people who will vouch for
you to come in we're catering primarily
to sort of the top two thousand
producers directors distributors finance
ears in the world to try and maintain
quality so we are heavily cure
dating but we've already attracted about
two and a half billion dollars and
capital representation on the platform
we've got about 200 features on the
platform the first 20 features have
completed financing and they've gone on
to all the major festivals and have sold
one of the first films that we landed on
our platform which unfortunately our
investors didn't get to get into but it
was still on our platform was the way
way back which got released this summer
there's another film called Roman
Polanski odd man out which is getting
released in october and there's just a
slew of films now there are four films
in Toronto and the week yeah I mean well
I there's there's so many that I lose
track we had about six films at Sundance
and another half dozen at Tribeca and
eventually I started losing count which
ones are going where but they're all
getting in and selling which is the most
important so let me ask you to follow up
questions that one is talk a little bit
and for people who don't know a little
bit about the jobs act and how has that
changed this business it's sort of very
new and I think people are still trying
to figure it out but and how does that
sort of affect the business about a
voyeur doing so the jobs act hasn't
changed anything we all hope it will and
when it was passed or signed into law a
year and a half or you might just
describe it for so the JOBS Act sorry is
really to help legalize the process of
crowdfunding so that it used to be that
you are limited to how many investors
you could reach out to they had to be
people who had an existing relationship
with all of these protections were put
in God 70 years ago a hundred years ago
I don't you remember to protect small
mom-and-pop investors from being duped
by some nefarious Wall Street firm now
obviously that still happens but the
process of raising money now has
completely changed you no longer just go
to your aunt and uncle and a few friends
you now go to your social network and
it's way easier to go raise small
amounts of money and we've seen the huge
successes you know Zach Braff was here
he'd be telling us all about the few
million dollars he raised on Kickstarter
so the JOBS Act is designed to make that
legal but there are limitations there
you can only raise up to a million
dollars you can only have so many
unaccredited investors or
unsophisticated investors they can only
invest up to
ten thousand dollars or ten percent of
their income there is all sorts of
auditing requirements that come into
play so all of a sudden the JOBS Act
looking a little bit complicated so the
time it will take to roll these things
out and uncomplicate the things the SEC
has recom placated who knows how this is
going to play out so in the interim
companies like slated have just decided
to go ahead and register and become a
broker-dealer which is that daunting
horrendous task where you have to study
and I'll get all these series exams past
we just decided to bite the bullet so
that we can do everything legally
without being limited by the potential
eventual Jobs Act do you do you think
there's a danger in sort of
democratizing investing in films I mean
you obviously you have a huge sort of
educational component to your to your
site as well you know it's it's as if
everybody all of a sudden can write a
check do you think that's sort of
muddies the process a little bit or you
are you excited about that well overall
you're letting anyone who actually is
interested in something to finally
participate so I think that's good for
everybody but as but it's an investment
right I mean you you give them returns
on there yes I mean instead instead of
literally giving $10,000 to Spike Lee so
you can watch a basketball game with him
you now can actually own a piece of the
upside of his next film maybe so the
idea is as people will donate but only
up to so much you know an impulse
donation of 50 bucks easy for some
people and impose donation of 5,000
bucks easy but eventually get to a point
where you want to own a piece of the
upside you know everybody here is
probably donated something small how
many people here have actually given
some sort of small donation to a
friend's project on any crowdfunding
platform okay a lot how many of you have
invested in something and it was more
than what you donated a one to one
person you mean on cakes how many people
just invested into anything like actual
owned equity or stock okay so smaller
number of you but but more than you
donated perhaps so I you know when you
look at the numbers there's a mass
market of people willing to invest in
stuff and a smaller market of people
willing to give so the idea is is we
want to unlock that potential now with
that you have to get educated along the
way the idea is not just to go blow
money one time and realize it was a
terrible investment and ever do it again
it's you got to learn to ride the
bicycle properly first before you start
you know getting into some sort of a
rally so we are helping educate less
sophisticated investors we're pairing
them up with more sophisticated
investors on slated so people are
gradually learning I think it's going to
be a 10 to 20 year process of growing
into sort of the comfort zone of
investing and did it my last question
when they invest do they have a say in
sort of the film I think if Elijah or
zach braff are sitting here he would say
that part of the reason why he went to
Kickstarter was because he wanted total
control the film himself and and you
know of the decisions and so forth that
would that would be made from it do your
investors get to pick the location
because it's cheaper where they're gonna
shoot or the sound you know because it's
cheaper et cetera do they have a say in
it artistic say the the short answer is
it's entirely up to the filmmaker so the
power of these platforms is that it
takes the power away from a Harvey
Weinstein and it puts it more into the
hands of Quentin Tarantino you're
putting the power back into his hands
now Quentin can decide i want to give
10,000 basketball court side seats away
to my fans or he could decide i want to
let that one person give me 10 million
dollar check hi you know be in the film
so it's up to Quentin the power goes
back into his hands so that's really
totally up to the filmmakers we're just
there to you know bring you
introductions and then you can do with
it whatever you want five years before
the facebook com would lie that's true
and five years before YouTube would love
yes so you're the oldest person on this
panel trato in it when it comes to this
well we'll get to your history in a
minute but um but but tell us how have
you seen how is college humor change how
have you seen this entire space
change I mean it's ten years ago as you
know we're huge yeah so when we first
started college humor we were basically
one of the only user generated content
sites on the web and that was still a
unique idea I mean how did you come up
with that so it was my best friend from
high school and I went to different
colleges and his brother worked for
company the time called techno surf it
later was renamed advertising calm and
his brother one day was like hey guys if
you you know there's this thing you can
do if you can get a people to a website
you can put ads on it it's like a
newspaper and then you can make money
and so my friend and I were like let's
start a website and we basically took
photos and videos that our friends would
take and put them on on a site and then
other people from other colleges started
contributing so that's how it became
this user generated site and and it was
you know it's very novel at the time
there's no other platform for people to
upload their own stuff so that was kind
of the genesis of it and and so how have
you seen sort of the whole shift change
and how are you adapting to them yeah so
I mean I think there's a lot of factors
so we started we also started vimeo in
2004 2005 and that was you know Vimeo
YouTube came out around the same time
and that's really been the big shift of
it it doesn't you no longer need a
curator everybody's a curator and and
that's certainly shifted things it's
I've seen our brand expand into we we've
done books and TV shows and we just did
our first movie it's really taking
things off you know out of that core
that core web property but always
keeping the web property active because
that's where the audience comes back to
every day and if you don't have a
relationship with your audience every
day you're going to lose him and when we
first started out we looked at the
history of the National Lampoon and we
saw that you know they had their their
magazine and then they had their
breakthrough movie and they were on the
right track but their magazine went from
monthly to buy month late to quarterly
to yearly and they weren't in the face
of their fan
very frequently and I kind of lost them
and it being a national lampoon fan
didn't mean as much when it was just a
movie every few years how have you and
how is the site also adapted to mobile
what what percentage of your videos and
so forth or walks approaching fifty
percent and it's I was talking to our
editor-in-chief the other day and I was
like when our writers write we should we
should write not write it on the phone
but when we view a piece view it on the
phone instead of viewing it on the
desktop because that's what that's where
most people are going to see it and you
know if you're and so you adapt have you
have you shot in closer or other been
sort of we've been making different so
we so most of our sketches that we've
done for the past ten years are three
minute four minutes sketches and that's
what we've become known for that
something we pioneered and now we look
at that and we say okay well if we're on
set shooting a sketch it's going to end
up at four minutes let's see what ten
second clip we can get you net though
now that we have those actors and we
have this stage we've rented these props
what can we do that's that's very very
small and then we'll post that to our
Instagram or we'll post it to our
Facebook or something like that and
smaller stuff tends to get shared even
more frequently um Steve big frame runs
Bam Bam oh right which is a YouTube
channel which you mentioned it was also
part of the got funding from YouTube and
YouTube decided to give over a hundred
million dollars of sort of original
content to different people talk to us a
little bit about how that channel has
been going and sort of do you think that
what YouTube did by giving content
creators money to create content on
YouTube was that a success now with a
little bit of hindsight no vote of
hindsight well I mean I think from
YouTube standpoint it was a success
because it got everybody talking about
YouTube and it got everybody's focused a
little bit turned over there and how do
I get money who got money like all of
that stuff and and they got into the
press and i think at that's at the time
when their numbers were just going like
this it was it was basically good
marketing for youtube the program itself
i mean we actually got a second
the funding but very few companies did
and it was like I said before they where
they really let down everybody just
assumed well they're gonna spend a
hundred and something million dollars on
content creation there's going to be
some marketing that's going to come
behind it and they just literally had
none there's like upload it and
collaborate with each other and stuff
like that and so that left a really bad
taste in everybody's mouth because it
was a lot of work and people put time
into it and you know they didn't they
didn't have any chance of ever recouping
the money and only very few of us ever
got to where we were getting tens of
thousands even of Yuuzhan on a video so
knowing what you know now would you have
done it again I would have done it
totally differently again really which
is what we're doing with our second
round of financing so we're with our
second round of financing we we gave
them for what they were asking for they
gave us the money and then we said well
we're not doing that you know we're not
doing the same thing again that's right
so specifically though what would you
have changed so basically what we
changed is for one our strategy at the
beginning was to was to work with our
community of big youtubers to create a
channel we didn't do a really good job
of thinking of think of looking at the
data and making sure that their
audiences were homogeneous right so that
the power of of creating a network any
kind of network is is that you're
hopefully showing them a little beats
bits and pieces of content that all fit
together and and where you can grow an
audience like college humor has you know
what you expect when when you go to
college humor and because you go there
when they show you something new that
you've never seen before you're more
likely to sort of watch it and so our
first attempt we mixed artists that were
sort of wrong for one another and so we
didn't get the marketing benefit and so
now basically what we're doing is we're
investing it and even actually a less
expensive content but we're holding back
more than half of the money to do
marketing against the content so it
seems like in jump in but it seems like
cutting through the clutter right that's
that's what everyone's dying to do and
that's what you know especially now that
there's all this other content original
kind of and so forth it's just like get
me through this clutter
so people yeah I see that I mean there
we have one main CollegeHumor channel
and it's one of the one of the biggest
on YouTube but we're starting to peel
off individual shows from that channel
because when people subscribe to a
YouTube channel their subscribing they
want to subscribe to a show and not a
network if you think of it you know in
the in TV terms and so if you just have
a bunch of kind of incongruous things in
that in what they're subscribing to
you'll see a lot of unsubscribes when
you post something that that doesn't fit
and I mean I think I'll add this
together we have people fighting with
each other in the comments this sucks I
want more of that it's like oh that was
a mistake yeah oh that's just so and
i'll add to the question about the
youtube first you'd youtube round of
funding and whether it worked or not i
think one of the problems was they gave
money to a lot of people who are used to
making content that talks at people but
not two people and and i think if you
know if you and they all said they don't
know if you guys like this but you got
you got credited per minute of content
you made which is just kind of a crazy i
mean youtube knows that that's not a
great way to do it but for some reason
like you you're rewarded by putting a 20
minute video on youtube just just
doesn't work you'd have to apply an
algorithm to it yeah not to mention they
give money to some of the celebrities
like you know Ellen not to knock on
Ellen DeGeneres but Ellen DeGeneres has
to talk a daily talk show I think she
wants to keep the daily talk show not
move to just making content continuously
for youtube so i always seem like a
short live play we have we've moved 10
minutes and and there's there's so much
to discuss but the underlying sort of
theme i think of this panel or a lot of
why this panel has come together raise
because technology is trying to disrupt
for lack of a better word hollywood the
entertainment industry this weekend we
got sort of a roundup of the summer and
what the summer did on the box office
and and sort of quoting the New York
Times North America for this summer
total totaled 4.7 1 billion dollars in
box office right which was a 10.2
percent increase over the same period as
last year attendance rose in the box at
the theater 6.6
% to about five hundred and seventy
three million people okay these numbers
are huge and it would seem Hollywood's
doing pretty well right what do you each
sort of thing is the one thing that is
really missing in Hollywood and what
needs to be disruptive or disrupted go
ahead put those stats you can always
kind of move those numbers around to
make it sound good and variety has done
that for a long time arm but if I was
quoting the New York time they're always
right there wasn't even here comes Devon
detail but you know having um a lot of
that I think is now foreign demand right
so there's those were American numbers
okay yeah yeah prop profitability I
would I would always question and you
know studio counting better than I do
it's not always as transparent as slated
so I I wonder it seems to me like
they're making less movies and they're
obviously they're they're not paying
attention to sort of the adult dramas
that are out there because other people
are figuring out how to make those
movies for niche audiences um so I don't
mean that but that's a that's not a
small detail that's the most critical
figure that wasn't quoted how much did
it cost them to make those movies and
market those movies because everyone in
Hollywood knows that the cracks are
showing and this sounds a lot like in
1999 when advertising in newspapers was
at an all-time high and they were
laughing at all the the notion that the
internet was destroying newspapers and
we all know what happened in the next
decade so that this is sort of the last
big stretch as they try to completely
retool they're going to have to retool
another question is is it going to be a
nice gentle soft transition or is it
going to be a really hard fall because
for the moment the end of that long tail
is just growing and growing donations
side keep growing what we're doing is
going to keep growing and they can
either keep ignoring that until it's too
late or gradually take a cue from that
and come up with more efficient ways of
making the films and get an appealing
more to niche audiences do you think
Kickstarter and the way of financing
films through Kickstarter we obviously
saw two very huge successes one in
Veronica Mars one in zach braff's film
is here to stay and will continue to be
sort of a force years to come yes
most people who haven't been in the film
industry probably don't realize but soft
money which is basically money you don't
have to recoup has always existed now
it's come from larger foundations it's
come from tax breaks government
subsidies instead of you giving your tax
money to a government and a government
writing a check you give directly to it
now so I can be super targeted and give
it to one movie I love or a bunch of
different things but it's no longer
through a different entity so it's just
a more personal engagement but the more
you raised through donations the more
appealing it gets to investors because
that's non recoupable so Zach Braff
raised three million dollars for his
film it's a 5 million dollar budget film
2 million dollars coming from investors
so investors are putting in to and
getting 5 and value so you can get away
with that for a while before donors
eventually say hey we want to get a
piece of the upside but the point is
there's a new balance taking place
between what investors want and donors
want and that's fantastic for the
industry and I think in another part
that we've all mentioned and I want to
talk to you Ricky about this is
marketing a film right you can make a
film for call it 20 million dollars then
you market it for a hundred million
dollars then you have to recoup 120
million dollars you're even break even
you've marketed a film your first film
and barely spent you spent sixty
thousand dollars a market where ya
nothing I mean that the test so we
released our first movie about a month
and a half ago it's called coffee town
and we shot it for you know couple
million bucks which is nothing in the
world of big-budget features and we
market it for nothing the reason we were
able to market it is because we have a
platform which we could use we have you
know 20 million monthly readers who read
our site and and we can put it on there
we have one of the biggest YouTube
channels so when we put our trailer in
the YouTube channel it instantly had
half a million views instead of you know
somebody starting from scratch putting
on youtube and just trying to get the
word out so I really think there's going
to be people who have promotional
platforms will start taking advantage of
that and start promoting their own stuff
instead of other people's stuff I mean
when we started CollegeHumor we didn't
know any advertisers so we started a
t-shirt company so we could become our
own advertiser and I think that's going
to happen a lot more with people as
they're like well I have a big
phone what can I shout I mean I think
that these guys oh sorry I'm just let's
does anyone have any questions in the
audience sir do we even Mike firm hi you
just spoke about the classic case of
low-end disruption with big studios not
realizing what is happening with sort of
film financing but how do you then
reconcile distribution and marketing
right are you going to be distributing
on on YouTube channels for these
full-length movies or is there in the
plans a way to reach the consumer and
market the movie to the consumer without
being in big theaters well if you brace
the collective right the plumbing is
there on distribution you can now almost
collateralize the demand right so if a
million people aren't investing in a
movie all of a sudden you have a million
advocates to help market your movie so I
think you can really start to provide
economies of scale there yeah I mean we
for coffee town we went every rebel to
get on every cable provider for VOD
Amazon iTunes voodoo I mean literally
Xbox anywhere you wanted it was same day
and there are companies now that can
just do that for you there's there's a
particular example I'd like to use
called margin call so I don't know if
everybody saw that movie or heard about
that movie but that movie was made for
three and a half million dollars it was
released simultaneously on iTunes and in
theaters the theater was viewed purely
as a loss leader so it was its marketing
event and it made the vast majority of
its money through itunes because of it
took advantage of all the publicity that
was happening right there and then with
a simultaneous release so filmmakers are
beginning to realize that distribution
you need new types of distributors
thinking differently about the most
effective way to find an audience okay
margin call it's about high finance and
the financial crisis that's going to
appeal really to a much more narrow
audience of bankers and banker haters
and how do we get to them and can we get
on a platform where we can efficiently
market it and take advantage of all the
PR we're getting and not
have to spend 30 million because by the
way that's the minimum a studio you know
wants to spend on marketing for any film
so that's why they have to make big film
when we're making and I'm an agent and
so I look this carefully when you're
making casting decisions will a actor
social media presence now fit into that
will you have to pay that actor more I
would hope so but you know and summer
than in building out that film if it's
for a digital film absolutely I'd say
not as much if it's like I mean Fifty
Shades of Grey like that's a big movie
people gonna see that no matter who's in
it but for us with with Ralph is
auditioning right but with that with
that too too soon so with our movie we
were able to go to individual peoples so
we have stars from in our movie always
sunny Friday Night Lights Parks and Rec
eastbound and down and we also have had
Josh Groban the singer and so we were
able to go to all of the fans of all
those TV shows and Mark it directly to
them and customize the ads based on who
we were marketing to so if you're a fan
of Parks and Rec we would put Ben
Schwartz in the thumbnail of the trailer
and have it play automatically on your
Facebook page and the biggest surprise
to me was how big josh groban's fan
bases and it is it was like this hidden
gem where we were like oh my god this
guy has millions and millions of fans
across the globe we can market directly
to them and they will go nuts and reblog
at Nassif and and so it matters if it's
a if you're the marketing depends on
social talk let me let me ask just sort
of one final question there's been a lot
of buzz recently about the new CEO of
Yahoo how she because she beat out sort
of the the interim CEO because he wanted
to become a Content he wanted yahoo to
become a Content company and she wanted
yahoo to become a tech company when you
as CEOs as founders of your companies
are you trying to compete with the
warner brothers in the Disney's of the
world and become a Content company or
are you trying to compete with the
facebooks and Google's of the world and
become a tech company well for me it's
yeah we're trying to become a Content
company and we're trying to do it by
being by taking advantage of all of
these tools that are being built me one
thing that's
some for companies any kind of contact
content company right now is that
venture capital does want to invest in
platform companies and so as you're
running a media business now basically
your phone never stops ringing from some
startup that just got five million
dollars in his building a widget to do X
and it's been uncanny how we've been
running our business and in getting to
the point where like we you know we're
whiteboarding something and we need this
and within a week somebody's called us
and we find out there's three companies
and they want to give it to a see you
are you want to be a Content company
because you can sort of by or acquire
some house the tech of it well yeah I
mean I've just seen that access to data
and access to better analytics access to
more efficient ways of doing things
makes makes great companies and makes
makes us super super quickly 20 seconds
yeah be you want to be both I mean not
good it's a false choice i think there's
so much area in white space in between
and just a plug for Ricky and
CollegeHumor the startup guys sort of
encapsulates that whole startup scene
and the absurdity of it but it's both
sides don't necessarily they're not very
introspective or see the other side it's
always a balance between art and science
there's so much opportunity in between
final thought yeah that makes sense
alright great do thank you very much
you